how do you deal with being evaluated
specifically by different people with
different opinions and motives oh how do
you deal with being evaluated well I can
tell you right now nobody likes being
evaluated right nobody hmm now you might
get somebody that says oh I love being
coach cinch and there are some people
that are pretty positive about that and
as a matter of fact I have clients where
they want to be coached right but most
people especially in a normal
environment like if you go out new hire
someone to coach you okay but most
people in a normal environment they
don't like being evaluated they don't
like being judged yeah always judging so
the first thing you have to do when it
comes to being evaluated is get that in
your head that you like everybody else
has defense mechanisms and they're gonna
flare up as soon as somebody says
something critical of you as soon as
somebody goes to evaluate you your
defense mechanisms are going to go up
and then once that happens once you feel
those defense mechanisms go up you got
to put your ego in check mm-hmm you got
to put your ego in check and then once
you do that you gotta listen listen I
know it sounds crazy listen to what
they're saying don't even don't even
think of a response say to yourself you
know what I'm not even gonna respond I'm
only going to listen to what they're
saying yeah but in two kind of em you're
already you can't even take it no no I
can't take it oh I'm saying but I think
because people will quote-unquote do
that but they won't really do it as far
as just I'm not gonna say anything I'm
just gonna listen yeah there that that's
actually like that's actually like it
that's actually how they set it up to
look I'm not saying exact exactly what
I'm talking about that you don't or
they'll all body language you know the
kind where they're like you know they'll
do that kind of stuff don't do that
don't do that
so so you're right you got to listen and
not just listen but truly listen not
listen just with your ears but listen
with your mind and your brain and with
an open mind an open mind and then think
about what people are saying and then
see it is important to see it from their
perspective because if you just see it
from your perspective you're not even
seeing what the criticism really is
you're only seeing the defence of the
criticism so actually get in their mind
and say wow what does this look like
from their perspective why would they be
taking the effort and the risk and the
challenge of trying to present this
problem to me if it wasn't important
mm-hmm are they just doing it just to
make me mad no they're trying to help
you and you know what just like just
like a joke you know they say like every
joke has some little truth to it every
little criticism even if the person is
your archrival their criticism is built
on something so what is that reality
that you can take away from it even
though you got to take it with a grain
of salt especially if the person like it
says here if the person has different
opinions and motifs well of course they
have different opinions you want people
with different opinions maybe they have
different motives so maybe you think
they're trying to usurp your authority
or something like that so maybe you got
to take it with a grain of salt but find
the grain of truth in there too and find
what it is from their perspective what
the problem is and learn from it and one
of the most beautiful things about this
is you take the criticism and you make
adjustments you know how do I deal with
about being evaluated I try and accept
the evaluation and make adjustments to
improve myself as a human hmm that's how
I deal with being evaluated and I'm not
saying I deal with it anybody better
than anybody else
because everybody gets defensive myself
included
hmm you know we had a little
conversation when we started tonight
right sure you said I repeated some
stuff on the last pot
allegedly and you know and then we
talked through it and then I said you
know and you know I noticed that your
camera work was a little bit off and you
know it was just to put my point was is
to prove how defensive we all get and we
all get and you know what I did I said
you know what I noticed that too
you know as far as me repeating there
was a couple little sections and it was
because we pulled from multiple
different books and they had a little
bit of overlap and looking back on it
probably shouldn't have but at that time
I thought you know what this is
emphasizing really important points yeah
but still people don't want to hear the
same thing over and over again so I
probably shouldn't have done that so
guess what
criticism accepted and on I will adapt
adjust and I will make improvements to
my game based on your criticism of my
technique my skill and my life